mais ne serait ce pas ce bon vieux
monsieur heureux qui vient vous
présenter un smartphone aujourd'hui mais
oui exactement c'est ça comment vous
allez j'espère vous allez bien tout se
passe bien ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle regarder ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
regarder ce qu'on a on va plutôt se
mettre dans l'eau c'est ça c'est le
nouveau smartphone de rim miss et leur
île 1008 pro reli vous connaissez la
marque de smartphones au bois de jeunes
gens nés présenter un paquet et
l'algérie avec une nouvelle série c'est
la série 8 et on va commencer
aujourd'hui en parlant du ried mi-8
propre et se réunit huit pros il
intéressant parce que déjà et coûte
moins de 300 euros et coûte 299 euros et
qu'est ce qu'on va avoir pour le 199
euros c'est ce que je vous demande c'est
ce que je vous demande ça ne savais pas
mais leurs yeux vous le dire vous y
retrouver surtout quatre caméras
l'arrière alors même si parmi les quatre
n'a pas forcément quatre qui vont me
haïk et moi mais on a une deux qui ont
vraiment mérité la première caméra un
capteur de 100 8 mégapixels mais je ne
détaille cependant quelques instants le
deuxième salle ultra grand-angle on voit
ce que l'état y est c'est tout ce que
j'aime bien moi c'est ça la regarde et
là des rigolos c'est pas mal
alors là pour le coup je vais vous dire
la sas et différencions ayant tout cas
sympa alors j'aime bien déjà cet effet
gris avec un peu de matière on n'est pas
sur un dos en verre on est sur un 2
plastique mais ça fonctionne bien l'idée
d'avoir les quatre capteurs comme ça
aussi ça fonctionne pas mal le branding
readme hockey why not
après c'est un grand standard 1 vous
avez retrouvé sur le côté bouton de
volume bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre de la recharge en usb c'est
une prise jack oui une prise jack dans
ce segment de prix et c'est normal
tiroirs de cartes sim avec double nano
symplus carte micro sd pour le monter
jusqu'à 512 gia un micro pour la
réduction de bruit qui est situé là
juste là là il est là le micro pour la
réduction de bruit et après regardez
c'est très classique vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
venir le déverrouiller sa déverrouille
ça va vite et ça c'est bien d'envoyer
fait plein de belles promesses il est
cool et c'est ce qu'on regarde
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime quand ça commence comme ça
regardez moi ce smartphone on a un écran
ici super amoled on diagonale de ses 24
pouces full hd plus avec un taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 180 m on le
voit là on a un écran poinçonnet vous le
voyez là là pour venir
planqué la petite caméra de celle fille
ok pourquoi pas et surtout il est pas
très lourd il fait à peine ses 176 g
sasso talas centre d'apparat smartphone
assez compact assez léger de fin août
cham énorme alors faut y aller à demain
si ça vaut le cas de tous ces grands
vous vous en douterez il faut
franchement est allé à demain et surtout
ce que j'aime bien là dessus c'est la
finesse il fait 8,1 mm d'épaisseur il
est assez fin la prise en main est
plutôt ok donc ça ce sont vraiment des
points intéressants si vous voulez un
smartphone qui est pas trop gros pour la
smart phones up compact l'existence de
couleur mois céline fnac blacks ont dit
que c'est un noir mais bon pour moi tire
plus sur le gris quel modèle en bleu si
vous préférez le bleu ici on va avoir un
haut parleur mono pour venir écouter vos
films vos séries tout ça sur youtube
voir monsieur gros bien évidemment
d'ailleurs pensez à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait j'ai mon haut
parleur mono cayla l'a donc la leçon
bien juteux de ce côté-là ça c'est fort
quand même regardez là ça sature un
petit peu si vous le pousse à fond et ça
c'est assez normal mais y'a du son quand
même un séjour découverte ni résumé dans
l'image c'est assez lumineux mais je
n'ai pas mis à fond mais a si je pousse
à fond parce que tu arraches un petit
peu les yeux ne sera peut-être pas le
smartphone le plus lumineux de l'année
mais je trouve que une fois de plus à
moins de 300 euros
là dessus il fera vraiment bien le
boulot pour augmenter l'expérience audio
vous mettez votre petit casque ici que
vous veniez branches et ça s'est super
bien et en plus on pouvait lire
également un père et un casque bluetooth
parce que oui vous avez du bûto 5.0
réussi et ça c'est bien c'est un
smartphone qui tourne avec un snapdragon
720 g ce qui permettra certes on n'est
pas tous les jeunes mais 80% sans aucun
problème donc là c'est vraiment pratique
vous avez soit sygic abraham soit 8 giga
draps moi j'ai une version 828 heures la
techno drame c'est la haye pays bas 4 x
la techno de stockage c'est de lui et
fès 2 points en une fois de plus à moins
de 300 euros c'est complètement logique
et ça ira parfaitement bien pour trouver
une grosse batterie de 4500 millions
terreur et surtout ce qui est bien là
dedans c'est que vous avez forcément un
bloc de charge
regardez moi ce monstre c'est un bloc de
charge 65 watts et vous avez de la
recharge jusqu'à 50 watts et de la
recharge rapide
ce qui permet de le recharger jusqu'à
50% en 17 minutes et jusqu'à 100% en 47
minutes autant vous dire que ça va vite
ça va très très vite toute l'expérience
logiciel sert il me why alors je sais
pas si vous connaissez read me why ça
fonctionne bien et les oisiens sais pas
si vous êtes coutumier de cette
expérience là on retrouve sensiblement
tous un grand classique un thème clair
thèmes sombres
ok il y en a pour tous les goûts vous
pouvez venir laisser la luminosité
automatique les modes confort des yeux
qui va venir légèrement jaunir mais
c'est pas déconner franchement j'ai
connu des modes confort des yeux qui
était bien moins bien que celui là cela
il est plutôt bien après vous pouvez
mettre un peu plus chaud un peu plus
froid mais le réchauffer un peu quand
même ça c'est important de me réchauffer
un petit peu son écran toutes les
questions de sécurité localisation bon
là on comprend rapidement comment ça se
passe la gestion des applis vous avez
votre tiroir d'applications qui
planquaient jusque là dans lequel vous
avez vos applications et je voudrais
vous avez dû annuler ses rendez vous le
voyez s'il a le nfc en fait l'année
s'est il est planqué justice il a pour
le paiement dématérialisé pour les
transports en commun pour le but et puis
je vous le disais vous avez la partie
photo regardez-la la pop là on se
rapproche on a parti photo avec un
capteur principal c'est lequel je ne
suis là à la csu nyala c'est le capteur
sans 8 mégapixels c'est un capteur de
samsung que vous avez ici qui permettra
de faire neuf pixels en un an alors ça
sert à quoi 9 pixels en est bien ça sert
à capter plus de lumière pour partir de
100 8 mégapixels est allé jusqu'à 12
mégapixels et surtout en conditions de
faible luminosité et en gardant quelques
instants donc ça c'est vachement
intéressant vous avez également c'est un
ultra grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et
quand je chante billon 219 degrés qui
ouvre à f 2.25 comme ça je vous dit tout
vous avez un capteur macro 1 ça doit
être un des deux là captant macro de 2
mégapixels couvre f 2.4 et puis vous
avez un capteur monochrome également de
2 mégapixels et une caméra de self
itunes 16 mégapixels couvre f 2.48 alors
avec tout ça pour venir faire des photos
en faible luminosité prendre en photo
tous vos potes par la vidéo jusqu'en 4k
30 images par seconde il ya plein
d'effets et les trucs rigolos il ya des
modes portrait assez marrant il ya une
cible jeune là dessus très clairement
rugby vient chercher une cible jeune et
on le voit ne serait-ce qu'au niveau du
look et au niveau du positionnement
tarifaire donc les filtrer tout ce que
vous voulez bien vous en avez une
tartine là dedans et ça c'est assez
marrant vous avez en plus à notre mode
qui est assez sympa c'est le
ul view vidéo qu'on retrouve dans
beaucoup de smartphones en début d'année
et que vous avez dans votre petit mode
là regardez vous venez ici en plus et
vous le retrouvez ici le dieu a les yeux
vidéo dont vous avez la caméra de celle
fictive - chaque la petite caméra sur le
dessus vous voyez hop là regardez notre
caméra en façade moniteur vous avez en
face à surtout on va commencer par une
photo sur le capteur principal ça
fonctionne pas trop mal là ça me crame
un peu en haut à gauche mais dans
l'ensemble c'est quand même relativement
correct dès qu'on passe en outre à 30
ans et vous le verrez ça vient jaunir
davantage on le voit sur la façade du
bâtiment et ça vient sature un peu plus
il ya quelques aberrations dans votre
approche sur les côtés là mais ça une
fois de plus ce n'est pas anormal et sur
un smartphone à moins de 300 euros ça me
paraît complètement logique
aidez vous voulez vous rapprochez un
petit peu en jouant on peut mais on perd
vraiment pression parce qu'on est sur le
capteur principal on vient où mais en
fait dans l'image on vient soumet son
sens 8 mégapixels donc on peut un peu
joué mais pas trop faut pas non plus
déconner la veille quelques images
capteur principal c'est vraiment pas mal
on voit bien les nuages les détails les
couleurs sont assez naturel c'est pas
trop mal luttera grand-angle et un peu
plus touché une fois de plus bon voilà
c'est c'est parce pas dingue dingue mais
ça fera le taf
quand vous avez la lumière on peut venir
ou non un peu on est plus sur le jeu
elles sont ultra grand-angle que sur le
capteur principal et on le voit surtout
attendez je voulais montre là on va bien
les bâtiments lagarde est là il est un
peu plus sur un espèce de gris un peu
légère touche de violine là il est jeune
on le voit clairement là on le voit la
garde et la halle ce qu'elle n'a été
vraiment sur le jaune mais trouve que
moi dans l'idée le capteur principal est
vraiment pas mal fait très bien le
boulot l'ultra grand temps est un peu en
dessous il vient davantage exposé il
vient poil plus saturé il est un peu
moins bon sur le côté là on le voit on a
quelques quelques petit problème il ya
le petit mais c'est normal une fois de
plus lyon là on le voit ici sur le côté
grand dieu pas terrible 1 sur la caméra
de celle fille à m'envoyer avec masque
et forcément les meilleures conditions
mais c'est pas dingue dingue au et la
regarde et on va c'est vraiment flagrant
et son ultra grand-angle prédit comme ça
bien saturé le sens interdit la par
rapport à la photo normal ça vient je
n'irai salia exposer davantage qui fait
que vocia montre un peu plus cramer
macro je suis pas trop fan j'ai toujours
un peu de mal effectivement un garde
trouver la bonne distance mais quand
vous avez trouvé la distance et ben ça
fait le taff et les trucs un peu rigolo
à faire mais il faut trouver une fois de
plus la bonne distance qui n'est pas
toujours évident et la photo nuit va je
suis pas un bon client pour ses photos
nuit là parce que vous n'avez aucune
stabilisation optique ce qui fait
qu'avec mon tremblements à regarder ça
se voit tout de suite ça se voit si vous
le posez sur un trépied vous avez
quelque chose un petit peu mieux
l'ultra grand pas
là avec le côté jeune c'est vraiment pas
terrible il faut oublier la nuit c'est
honnêtement pas le smartphone pour faire
des photos de nuit et surtout c'est un
smartphone qui est disponible dans deux
conflits mais surtout nous on va
s'intéresser à la config 828 8 gigas de
ram 128 go de stockage qui coûte 299
euros remy m'a demandé de vous parler de
leur offre alors il ya une offre à
partir du 24 mars jusqu'au 6 avril chez
fnac darty
vous avez des bugs kg faire donc en même
temps vous avez vos petits écouteurs
donc ça c'est assez sympa vous avez de
quoi faire le smartphone est sympa
j'aime bien me trouve assez rigolo et
franchement alors il ya plein de
produits dans ce segment là c'est
toujours compliqué de venir trouver le
produit qui est fait pour vous moi ce
que j'aime bien ici une fois de plus le
gros point positif c'est qu'il est assez
léger il est très fin vous avez une
caméra de 8 mégapixels donc on va venir
gagner en luminosité
le processeur est suffisamment puissant
pour attendait plein de jeux du pesto et
puis surtout cette boîte je regardais
mossala doigt les boîtes l'autonomie
vous tenez à peu près une grosse journée
une grosse journée une journée et demie
ça va dépendre de vous de vos usages ça
va dépendre de plein de choses de ce que
vous allez en faire mais si vous voulez
un smartphone sympa qui vous accompagne
partout qui se rechargent vite il fait
des photos avec capteur principal sorte
de quatre principales de bonne qualité à
ses fins et bien je pense que là vous
avez une solution qui est très cool
c'est leur il me 8 pro à noter qu'à une
version tout noir sans berthou leap qui
va sortir par contraire tous les
séquelles pas mal de laisser ça veut
dire aux et dépasser vos limites et il
va être disponible partout à partir du
31 mars sur cdiscount fnac darty amazon
electro dépôt et readme points comme ça
chez faire vous aimez les liens en bas
dans la description voilà ce que j'avais
à vous dire je voulais vous le présenter
parce que c'est une alternative qui est
assez sympa dites moi vous ce que vous
en pensez comment vous trouvez serez
1008 prouesse qu'il pourrait voter ce
que vous pourriez vous positionnez
est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté un
smartphone de rim mis les bottes jaunes
marqué le mois en bas aux commentaires
que l'on retrouve très vite et
extrêmement vite pour continuer à parler
de quoi parler de quoi ça parlait tech
bien évidemment de smartphones de plein
de produits et ça c'est très cool vous
fait des gros bisou pour des gros becs
non beaucoup d'amour au format plein de
coeur pour lé soin de vous et à très
vite
ciao